next on public lives a look at the
relationship between FDR and Winston
Churchill Jon Meacham managing editor of
Newsweek talks about his new book
Franklin and Winston an intimate
portrait of an epic friendship this is a
little under an hour I've already told
the audience as I was filling as the
what do they call the the at the
concerts the openers that we went to
Chartwell this summer and I took your
book along and and that was a great fun
it was to read about as we all know how
much fun it is to read about the person
that your whose house here's seeing and
it really the to the book became even
more alive and and certainly Chartwell
the Churchill's home became more alive
having reading John Meacham's book at
the same time I found both my husband
and I really enjoyed reading of the book
it's the relationship between these two
giants was incredibly interesting the
differences between the two men which
I'm sure John will tell you about
they're there but they were both they
had this this the they held their
country's in the palm of their hands
both of them and it was something that
maybe could only happen in a could have
only happened then maybe it could have
only happened in that Great War it's
hard to tell but these these figures I
don't think we may never see the likes
of them again so it's really with great
pleasure that I introduce Jon Meacham
who's down here from New York where he
is an editor of Newsweek magazine you
were doing so well I'm not sure I should
cut you all it's wonderful thank you I
apologize for bringing New York traffic
to your city Roosevelt and Churchill
though they built one of the great
friendships I think of modern times and
certainly the most fascinating
it was hardly love at first sight they
first met on a July night in 1918 at a
hall and called Gray's Inn and when the
old Inns of Court in London it was a
dinner for the very fancy dinner dinner
for the war ministers and the war
cabinet in the First World War and
Franklin Roosevelt was in 36 and
Assistant Secretary of the Navy and was
about as thrilled as he could possibly
be to be invited to this dinner he loved
it he sent detailed letters back home
there was one person who did not find
him quite as charming as President
Roosevelt apparently found himself and
that was the 43 year old former First
Lord of the Admiralty then the minister
of munitions Winston Churchill about 25
years later Roosevelt said to Joe
Kennedy Winston Churchill is the only
man in public life who's ever rude to me
he acted like a stinker lording it all
over us
six days after that meeting at Gray's
Inn a young corporal named Adolf Hitler
won the Iron Cross first class at the
front a decoration he would wear when he
declared war on both Great Britain in
the United States and it would be Hitler
of course who brought the two men back
together so tragically and yet so
wonderfully for for all of us they
ultimately spent Roosevelt and Churchill
113 days together during the war they
spent Thanksgiving together Christmas
New Year's they fished it at Hyde Park
and at Camp David
then shangri-la while they discussed
whether who was going to share the
atomic bomb where we were going
and how the war would be conducted the
enormous complexities of the war really
did come into them in a way that's hard
to imagine now they were very hands on
they sat in the map room they moved the
pens around and decided what what we
were going to do they loved him high
office pageantry patriotic poetry and
the sound of their own voices Mary
Soames who grew up the chart wolf where
you visited said to me with their
Winston and clementines youngest child
lady Soames was born in 1922 and was a
great source and friend for this book
she said sitting between Poppa and the
president was like sitting between two
lions roaring at the same time and they
both liked roaring at the same time
obviously in writing a book about a
relationship you have to decide in a
particularly a political relationship
how much of this was real friendship and
how much of this was simply the dictates
of the moment and I thought I'd tested
that throughout the process and I used
Eleanor Roosevelt chiefly as my my
witness and I asked true dilash Joe
lashes Widow who is in her 90s now and
still living in Greenwich Village in New
York I asked her whether one could trust
mrs. Roosevelt's memoirs and her
post-war recollections about the
friendship between the Prime Minister
and her husband and mrs. lash said you
must remember that mrs. R was one of the
most honest women who ever lived to a
fault she would usually pick the wrong
moment to tell you something that was
fundamentally wrong with your character
it was mrs. Roosevelt who described the
friendship as a fortunate one that we
were lucky indeed that the two men
enjoyed spending so much time together
for it made the problems of war easier
to solve and in fact the war easier to
win I also always take to heart the idea
that what men say outside of earshot of
the other without much expectation that
would be reported as good evidence
Churchill endlessly professed affection
to Roosevelt both to his face and behind
his back I love that man he is the
greatest friend we have ever had
and then to his face he said as late as
1944 you must run for reelection I
simply can't go on without you
Roosevelt did the same thing he was
Roosevelt as you all know was rather
stingy err emotionally rather chilly or
rather more distant but there was a deep
fondness there and he said both behind
his back and to Churchill that it was
fun to be in the same decade with
Winston Churchill it was a friendship in
Churchill's phrase forged in the fire of
war there was a telegram he wrote Ellen
Ellen today the president died in 1945 I
also think it's important I don't know
what your lives are like but in my life
friendships are always created by a
context CS Lewis once said we once wrote
we picture lovers face to face but
friends side by side their eyes look
ahead and I've always saw the image of
fishing buddies that they're friends
because they share an interest in the
fishing they share an interest in one
another of course as well but there's
definitely a bringing together and a
cement that is not necessarily that the
two people would not be so close if
that's submit we're not there and
there's no question that what brought
Roosevelt rohtul together was the fate
of democracy at its most critical hour
when I was talking to lady Soames about
this time summer day and 2000 I think in
her house sitting below a painting of
her father's from chart wall you know
Winston Churchill was quite a slacker as
you all know he wrote 52 books painted
about 300 high quality images and
managed to defeat a Dolf Hitler and did
most of it while drinking Johnnie Walker
red so a role model for us all I asked
her how genuine do you think the
friendship was between Papa though I
didn't say that and the president
she said that whenever she thought of
the president and Papa she thought of
the French proverb and love there's one
who kisses and one who offers the cheek
and the Prime Minister was always
kissing and Franklin Roosevelt was
always offering the cheek
the love affair metaphor runs throughout
the friendship with kind of bracing
candor that he was not always known for
Churchill said after the war that no
lover had ever studied the whims of his
mistress as I did those of Franklin
Roosevelt so what was it that made
Churchill so open so boisterous so warm
and Churchill and Roosevelt so cool and
distant chilly
I think the origins of those different
styles lie in their earliest days
Churchill's parents as you all know were
not would not win any awards today for
parent of the Year Lord Randolph was
cold and distant wrote unforgiving
letters remarkable letters poor Winston
broke a watch once and got three letters
from his father calling him a
harum-scarum boy told if he didn't get
cracked down in his studies he would end
up like all these public school wastrels
just he had to beg for any love or any
attention from both parents including
Jenny of course who was American and
lady Soames told me that she had she
ladies some said once asked a very old
cousin of hers whether Randolph and
Jenny had really been such awful parents
and the old cousin had paused and said
yes I think I think Churchill had
therefore had to reimagine reality that
upset him this is a man remember who
wrote a two-volume biography of his
father Lord Randolph Churchill I think
it was Gladstone who once said I can
handle the French and Lord Randolph but
not both at once he wore his father's
wrecker as father's robes his chance for
the Exchequer
when he succeeded him to that office and
he really decided these were the most
wonderful people in the world he said of
his mother that she shone for me like
the evening star brilliantly but at a
distance so he was accustomed to
reimagining things part of it part of it
also was his historical imagination he
saw the life as a great Renaissance
pageant in which he was a key player
Franklin Roosevelt had rather the
opposite problem when he came to
parental affection and
tension as you all know he was about 16
before mrs. Roosevelt let him bathe
alone he was kept a slight exaggeration
he was kept back from Groton for two
extra years he went at 14 when most boys
went at 12 he was absolutely smothered
in the attention that Churchill longed
for and I think he decided that he
needed to manage his mother and then
later came to manage although everyone
else in his life the same way which was
trying to control the flow of
information keep some secrets in order
to have a kind of zone of privacy to use
a contemporary term that he might not
have recognized but he used a code in
his diary he loved secrets throughout
his life and I think there was a kind of
emotional chill eNOS that came from his
wanting to always maintain his own
private self as much as possible and I
think it came to characterize virtually
every relationship in his life certainly
that with his wife which we'll talk
about in a second certainly that with
his aides and certainly that with
Winston Churchill there were basically
three acts to this kissing and turning
of the cheek Act one began on September
11th 1939 a momentous day even even then
when Franklin Roosevelt was president
wrote a letter to the newly restored
First Lord of the Admiralty Winston
Churchill offering a open channel of
communication to Washington saying
Neville Chamberlain was still Prime
Minister and the president said if you
have anything you want me to know about
send it through my pouch and I'll answer
you through yours which is a quite a
remarkable thing when you think about to
have a head of state of one government
inviting the cabinet member of another
it's like bush inviting Blair's Finance
Minister to communicate privately with
him so Roosevelt initiated what became
is epic friendship in in 1939 Churchill
could hardly contain himself
Churchill could hardly contain himself
of the time but he was so excited by
this he said we must not let the liaison
last and he hit on rather brilliantly
see stories
a way of keeping Roosevelt interested in
the British war effort Churchill I think
never got over being a war reporter you
know he loved details of battle and
wrote them well and sent Roosevelt
several accounts of early naval
engagements in that in that dismal fall
he of course became Prime Minister on
the 10th of May 1940 when the news was
brought to Roosevelt in the Cabinet Room
Roosevelt said well he supposed
Churchill was the best man England had
even he was drunk half the time hardly a
strong vote of confidence but both men
undertook the incredibly difficult work
of 1940 Churchill literally fighting for
the survival of Britain and I think of
freedom as we understand it today
and Roosevelt trying to push a nation
that poles 95 percent in the autumn of
1939 saying stay the hell out of the
whole thing and 65% I think said don't
sell anything to anyone they undertook
these incredibly complex tasks of
statesmanship with a vision of the other
in his mind each one did Roosevelt had
to determine whether Churchill was worth
making a bet on and Churchill knew that
and played to it and Churchill was quite
explicit that Franklin Roosevelt was his
hope the one of the most famous speeches
in the English language is the we shall
we shall fight on the beaches we shall
fight on the landing grounds we shall
never surrender what's not noticed is
the end of that speech the very last
point is in God's good time until in
God's good time the new world in all its
power and might shall come forth to the
liberation of the old that is a speech
that we read as defiant today that
actually is more a prayer than a
proclamation because Franklin Roosevelt
personified the new world and Churchill
was convinced that he had to have him to
win Pearl Harbor obviously brought them
together in December of 1941 although
not immediately which is another little
thing there's a great play could be
written about the four days between
December 7th and December 11th 1941 we
all think now Pearl Harbor happened
I went to the hill delivered the great
speech and off we were Hitler didn't
declare war on us until that Thursday
and in fact the speech on the 8th of
December does not mention Germany it
only mentions Japan so Churchill is
sitting in London realizing this reading
this very carefully and wondering quite
what he's up against will he in fact
have an American in America fighting a
Pacific war while he continues to have
to fight the European war to bridge that
gap he immediately invited himself to
the White House said I'll be right over
and it took it took Roosevelt three or
four days of staving him off and then
Hitler solved the dilemma in a mistake
from which he would never recover and
declared war on us on the 11th of
December which then began arguably an
exuberant and wonderful period of mutual
affection and shared interests from
December of 1941 until November of 1943
when Joseph Stalin came along rather
like as if Roosevelt and Churchill had
been going steady for a couple of years
and then a cool new girl showed up in
class and called Franklin Roosevelt's
eye there was a Sunday morning in June
of 1942 that I think is the great moment
where the personal affected the
political they had been Churchill
Roosevelt had been at Hyde Park for the
weekend it was terribly hot Churchill
hated the heat you know he would wear
these ten gallon Stetsons which I think
probably made it worse but he thought
helped and wear these thin clothes once
got up in the middle of the night
because it was so hot at Hyde Park and
went out and tried to get the breeze off
the Hudson they taken the overnight
train to Hyde Park to the White House
excuse me from Hyde Park and Churchill
had just finished breakfast and read the
papers it was coming across to the Oval
study there on the second floor of the
White House when the news came that the
important British garrison in North
Africa had fallen and they had
surrendered Tobruk the pain and anguish
on Churchill's face was so palpable he
was reeling that Roosevelt who could
play poker better than any president in
the 20th century simply reacted to the
emotional
his friend was in and said simply what
can we do to help and Churchill rather
brilliantly always thinking ahead always
said give us 300 Sherman tanks at that
point we had about 302 in the whole
arsenal but Roosevelt pick up the phone
called George Marshall and said make
this so and they did at great cost to
American Arsenal's the American Arsenal
at that point
Marshall was always concerned that we
that Britain would actually go down and
we would be stuck as the sole firewall
and having given all our crown jewels to
Britain not be prepared for it and might
be blamed for it but that was a morning
where they'd been fishing together
they'd been driving a Roosevelt loved to
ride around Hyde Park and drive up with
this car he had that he could use work
with levers and drive to the precipice
just before and squeal squeal to a stop
and make his guests think they were
going off into the heads and Churchill
was prompted to say at that point that
he had great prayers that the brakes
were working act three began in 1943
Stalin comes along Franklin Roosevelt
believes that it will emerge to be a to
superpower world he realizes the Soviets
are doing most of the fighting and most
of the dying which was true and played
up to Stalin to such a degree that on a
personal level one night at dinner
Winston Churchill bolted away from the
dinner table at Tehran and was the 30th
of November 1943 and Stalin had to go
get him and bring him back and it was
very much life is rather like high
school most of the time and even at this
high high level with the fate of
overlord
the time of the liberation of Europe the
fate of Poland whether or not the atomic
bomb would be working all these issues
floating around and yet the emotional
storm raging was such that the Prime
Minister of Great Britain felt compelled
to leave the room there was still vote
throughout all this a mutual affection
and a kind of a kind of joy each other's
company I think at Yalta at the very end
Churchill had grown more and more
loquacious as he as he got older in the
war and Roosevelt as you all know was
sick at that point
quite quite ailing and just tired easily
and he spent a day listening to speech
after speech from Churchill in Yalta and
came back to his room and Jimmy Byrnes
was there and he said you know Jimmy
Winston has just developed this terrible
habit of repeating these long speeches
he's given before and Justice Byrne said
well yes but they're good speeches and
Roosevelt had to chuckle and say well
Winston doesn't make any other kind
always sweet
Roosevelt's emotional complexity his
capacity to juggle he actually once said
I'm a juggler I never let my left hand
know what my right hand is doing was
truly remarkable and did characterize
all of these relationships and I'd like
to read something that emerged in my
research for this that is coming out for
the first time which is a letter from
Lucy Mercer Rutherford to the president
in 1941 a very quick thumbnail sketch I
suspect you all know but Lucy Mercer
came to work for Eleanor Roosevelt as
her social secretary in 1916 she and FDR
fell in love there was some kind of
affair such that the letter that love
letters from Lucy were discovered by
Eleanor coincidentally after FDR's
returned from the trip where he first
met Winston Churchill that 1918 trip
Eleanor gave President Roosevelt the
choice it was either her or Lucy the
president chose Eleanor and I think
perhaps not coincidentally his career
and they went on for a long time we've
had only the sketchiest idea of what
kind of contact
Lucy FDR might have had through the
years
and this letter emerged in the archives
at Hyde Park and you'll let me just read
to you a remarkable document we've known
that she returned to the president's
circle after her husband's death in 1944
and was of course with him on the day he
died in Warm Springs but this letters
from 1941 the Lucy Roosevelt connection
was deeper and more complex than that of
one old family friend to another tucked
away in the Roosevelt archives in Hyde
Park as part of a letter almost
certainly written in 1941 from Lucy to
the president whom she calls poor
darling long and handwritten alternately
practical emotional encouraging
sentimental chatty and sad the note
reveals much about the nature and extent
of their relationship her grasp of his
need to be reassured and bolstered and
praised her eagerness like Eleanor's to
give him counsel on politics in the mood
of the country even mentioning Churchill
her dependence on his judgment about the
affairs of her own family and most
poignant Lee a hint of her regret that
his sense of duty had along with the
coming of World War two foreclosed the
possibilities of a quiet life perhaps a
quiet life spent together the letter
indicates a striking level of engagement
with the nuances of each others worlds
Lucy jokes about catching a cold when he
has one because they talk on the
telephone as a dead-on understanding of
Harry Hopkins his role in the White
House knows about Roosevelt's travel
plans and refers to Barbara Rutherford
her youngest child as the smallest signs
that Lucy an FDR were in very close
contact as the president prepared the
nation for war the note was written
written from Aiken South Carolina where
the Rutherfords had a house on the eve
of a trip and Hill Roosevelt was
planning to take Lucy begins by offering
kind words about his plight in facing
isolationist sentiment and recommending
potential allies in the business
community day by day the news becomes
increasingly ominous and complex
and one feels that the responsible heads
of the democracies must indeed be
supermen or at least a dozen supermen to
each nation clothed the power of life
and death living as we do here in a
community of pleasure seekers who cannot
see farther than the gloves in their
hands
one is terrified by the lack of vision
or understanding of what is going on in
the world and so close to us the most
able man in these parts is George Meade
of the need corporation who served on
the businessmen's Council for a number
of years
I always feel he might be a help to you
in some capacity as an iron or outer of
sorts though I may have the wrong slant
on him I think you might get Harry
Hopkins to bring him to lunch with you
sometime when you are alone she then
turns to family matters this kind of
letter is best unwritten and unmailed
and poor darling to give you one more
thing to read or think about is
practically criminal though someday I
should like to ask your advice about my
youngest stepson who is studying law at
the University of Virginia and has one
more year he wonders if it would be more
interesting in better training for him
to take a job in Washington perhaps with
a political slant to it it seems to me
life in Washington where he could have a
house and a garden would be better than
life in New York where they say most of
the lawyers work themselves to death of
course the war may change everything and
making plans ahead these days makes very
little sense I am so thankful that
you're getting away soon the only thing
is that all your anxieties go away with
you
even your bad throat the smallest send
you her love bless you as ever l in an
almost dreamy PostScript Lucy talks of
things as she would like them to be and
possibly as she as she would like them
to have been affairs of the heart had
turned out differently in the last years
of the last World War PS time is closing
in on going-away time and I hesitate to
send this without last-minute
instructions have been housed with a bag
cold called over the telephone question
mark and not allowed out nevertheless
worried newspapers arrive a day late he
which is trying and radio reception the
worst in the world which is even more
trying I suppose now more than ever one
must live each day as it comes
if only it will be a friendly world a
small house would be a joy and one could
grow vegetables as well as flowers or
instead of oh dear there's so much I
should like to know how much hope you
have and the thousand questions one does
not like to ask an old gentleman here in
Aiken says you have a close agreement
with Churchill as to what will happen
after the war I know one should be proud
very very proud of your greatness
instead of wishing for the soft life of
joy and the world shutout one is proud
and thankful for what you have given to
the world and realizes how much more
must still be given this greedy world
which never asks in vain you have
breathed new life into its spirit and
the fate of all that is good is in your
dear blessed and capable hands I think
they were in touch I think that's a
remarkable letter and it shows a level
of engagement and a level of
sophistication and the level of grace
that has not always characterized
different presidential romances in our
time or in any time I think from this
and some other letters that are here I
don't know whether Franklin Roosevelt
was the great love of Lucy Rutherford's
life or whether Lucy Rutherford was the
great love of Franklin Roosevelt's life
but they clearly meant so much to each
other and clearly he found a kind of
comfort and a kind of solace and her
company unto the hour of his death for
which we should all be grateful I think
to mrs. Rutherford ultimately
FDR's reality was a mix of artifice and
affection like many politicians and I
thought I would close by reading a scene
from 1943 right before Tehran Churchill
has been in the United States for almost
seven weeks I think I think was as long
as sustained trip here he's gone to get
an honorary degree at Harvard
Roosevelt was very worried that they
have the right kind of hood and garment
he wanted Harvard to stand up to Oxford
in that way and it was September 1943
they knew they were going to meet with
Stalin Roosevelt knew in his heart I
think that he would be reaching out to
Stalin to Churchill's exclusion and this
is the last night at Hyde Park
it was the Churchill's 35th wedding
anniversary Clementine was there
it was time for Churchill to go home and
he accepted Roosevelt's invitation to
stop in Hyde Park before the Atlantic
crossing Roosevelt agreed to come to
England around the time of the invasion
d-day a prospect that elated Churchill
the day at Hyde Park Mary Soames wrote
past very happily the Churchill's
celebrated their 35th wedding
anniversary and Winston told Clementine
that he loved her more and more every
year
Roosevelt organized a small supper there
were cocktails and sherry by the
fireplace
Daisy Suckley Roosevelt's cousin gave
Mary a signed copy of the true story of
fahua a book sook Lee co-authored on the
president's Scottie the PM remarked on
how well the P looked Daisy wrote in her
diary we all agreed that it was
extraordinary it seems as though the
trials and difficulties of the office of
President in these days act as a
stimulant to the P Daisy noted they may
take the place of the exercise which he
can't have like other people Roosevelt
toasted the Churchill's at about 10:20
the president drove Churchill down the
hills to the special railroad siding it
was Daisy noted a beautiful moonlit
night and Churchill's train was waiting
passing beneath the trees the chug of
the blue Ford's motor motor echoing in
the quiet woods Roosevelt and Churchill
knew the most difficult battles and
issues lay ahead the cross-channel
operation the ongoing war against Japan
the atomic bomb the structure of the
United Nations Churchill still thought
he might be able to carry the day
perhaps control the timing of overlord
to produce to pursue the war in the
Mediterranean and in the long run
preserve britain's central role in world
affairs he hoped all this was possible
because of the man driving in through
the Duchess County night they were
friends was not anything possible if the
American President and the British prime
minister were together which they seemed
to be they came to a stop along the
Hudson just before boarding Churchill
leaned into Roosevelt's car god bless
you Churchill said
looking into the Prime Minister's face
now in the darkness Roosevelt may have
sensed the rising emotion in his guests
so many years together by now so many
decisions so many young men sent into
battle and it was really only the
beginning Roosevelt's own heart was
stirred I'll be over with you next
spring Roosevelt said Churchill boarded
a special my dear Franklin Churchill
wrote from the Train we've all greatly
enjoyed this trip and I cannot tell you
what a pleasure it has been to me to
clem me into Mary to receive your
charming hospitality at the White House
and at Hyde Park you know how I treasure
the friendship with which you have so
honored me and how profoundly I feel
that we might together do something
really fine and lasting for our two
countries and through them for the
future of all yours ever w Roosevelt's
reply was generous delighted you were
all safely home and I hope you had a
smooth run all is quiet here Congress
has been here for a week and it is still
quiet my best to all three of you the
Daisy sue Clayton had noticed something
else at that last supper there was she
told her diary a first very definite
chill of autumn as I said in the
beginning Eleanor Roosevelt described
this as a fortunate friendship and I
think we all indeed quite lucky and
blessed that Roosevelt and Churchill
were where they were when the crisis
came before we would no doubt be living
in a very different world if they had
not been there thank you all I would
love to take some questions with you
[Applause]
we'll have questions I see this
gentleman standing appropriately by the
microphone so that our friends on c-span
can also hear the questions I have to
ask that everybody approach the
microphone I before you get to ask a
question would you mind letting me ask
Jon Meacham to tell us a little bit
about how he got interested in this
subject since it happened so many it's
ancient history to him both my
grandfather's fought in the Second World
War one with the Third Army in Europe
and the other in the Pacific and so
Roosevelt and Churchill had were always
were part of the background of my
growing up and about five years ago I
had to deliver a eulogy for a very good
friend and I remembered rows of
Churchill's eulogy for Roosevelt in the
House of Commons which I'd read at some
point and went back to it and the
numbers just the sheer scope of the
relationship and the figures jumped out
at me of the 2,000 letters 120 days
together Churchill had that wrong by a
week but I think we'll let him get away
with that and I've gotten to know ladies
home slightly from some Newsweek work
and went to see her and when she quoted
that French proverb and love there's one
who kisses and one who offers the cheek
I thought it hop so but these were
wonderful men has been for years with
even with the secondhand smoke it was
worth it
sir would you say some more about the
relationship with Stalin and because I
mean that that really shaped the
post-war world when when rusa felt died
of course Churchill was left with Stalin
and Truman never could step into those
shoes that relationships oh that's right
no it's a great question
Stalin as you all know there's there's
been a long long time
kula thought that roosevelt was naive
about Stalin that he thought he could
manage him at bottom he couldn't be too
much different than other men and
Franklin Roosevelt had charmed everyone
else in his life why couldn't he charm
this Bolshevik dictator who killed
millions that was the limits of Franklin
Roosevelt's charm there's no question
that this was like the third person at
the party and Churchill felt it quite
keenly personally and politically
I believe I sort of walk with Averill
Harriman on this who said that the fault
of the Cold War lies with one person and
it's not Roosevelt and it's not
Churchill it's Joseph Stalin the armies
were where they've the Red Army was
where it was they had pushed very far
west obviously and Stalin was remarked
actually that whoever occupies a
territory militarily necessarily imposes
its political system it cannot be
otherwise and so I think that there was
a kind of a tragic inevitability to to
the Cold War that's controversial but
that's my view I also think Roosevelt
gets a bit of a bum rap on this when
Churchill came back from Yalta he said
Neville check poor Neville Chamberlain
thought he could trust Hitler but I know
I can trust Stalin Yalta was a much
warmer moment when you read the
communique when you read Sherwood's
Roosevelt in Hopkins which remains a
marvelous book there was a lot of hope
there and of course we all see Yalta as
the end but they didn't they thought
they were going to see each other in May
in San Francisco for the United Nations
they hoped to see each other in Berlin
which of course as you pointed out
Truman had to keep that date and Eleanor
Roosevelt said that she thought that
Franklin believed there would be more
meetings and more work I think it raises
an important point for our own age
actually which is that the best
politicians and the best statesmen
understand that politics is far from
clinical and requires constant work and
constant engagement with the
complexities of the issues and you I
read all this they spent hour upon hour
upon hour on you know the French
political structure which is sort of an
oxymoron
you know these they tried everything
they could do and so they were fiercely
engaged with this and drawing lines on
the map
working out deals Churchill whenever
Churchill was with Stalin he had liked
him except when they were the three were
together it's there's a there's a
wonderful man named Charles Ede whose
diary I think I'm the first person to
use in this book rather extensively who
is a newspaperman in London who was
brought in every other week or so sort
of to get them in our in our language
spun by the Prime Minister and he left a
diary and Churchill would come back from
these long drinking bouts in Moscow and
say well I breakfasted all of aspirins
but I'm convinced that I got my way in
night that sort of thing so it's it's
there's no the Churchill admirers in
here since the war have done a very
skillful job beginning with Winston
Churchill himself and the war memoirs of
avoiding the sort of unpleasant fact
that there was a lot of not blame
exactly but there was a lot of
responsibility to go round about not
seeing Stalin through and through I
don't think so and if Franklin Roosevelt
and Winston Churchill couldn't figure it
out I sure can't I don't I think no we
couldn't we barely you know Churchill
the other great controversial issue is
was Churchill too reluctant to hit the
French coast was he too haunted by
memories of Gallipoli and and other
terrible amphibious tragedies a concern
for the lives of one soldier should not
be a vice in my view so I think we
should be very generous minded when we
evaluate Churchill's record on this but
there was a joke it popped up in hearing
Wallace's diary where the phone rang at
Downing Street and Churchill picked it
up and said who's this and the voice on
the phone said Uncle Joe and Winston
said where you calling from
and Stalin says Calais they again today
good old Henry Wallace always there for
us that's old so that's another sermon
for another day but III don't think so
I think we spent 40 the Eastern Europe
spent 40 years in the grip of a terrible
terrible force but imagine we had to
remember the evil force we did to feed
for so many others ask you about that
first step in relationship back in 1939
when you said Roosevelt reached down to
Churchill did Neville Chamberlain know
about that initial contact and if so
what do you know about his reaction and
also what do you know about the
decision-making process for Roosevelt to
go into someone else's cabinet that was
fairly extraordinary it was that that
two great questions Chamberlain did know
Churchill again sort of we've lost this
in the distance of history Churchill was
very respectful of Chamberlain even
after May of 1940 he kept Chamberlain in
the loop because remember Churchill was
seeing how to put it as a bounder as a
joke Kennedy wrote Roosevelt a letter
saying Churchill's turned into a fine
two-fisted drinker and his judgment is
never proven to be too good I mean the
whole view of Churchill before 1940 was
you know as Churchill's best friend in
English life Effie Smith Lord Birkenhead
his best friend said when Winston's
right he's right and when he's wrong my
god that was his friend so and then
Churchill had always been rather erratic
so Chamberlain wanted to Chamberlain
represented to Churchill Tory approval
and remember the King did not want to
send for Winston Churchill on the 10th
of May 1941 to send for Lord Halifax of
course who was later sent to Washington
as ambassador and we would be living in
a very different world if that had
happened but Chamberlain did no I don't
think he was thrilled about it
Chamberlain used to say it's best to
count on nothing from the Americans
except words and it's true we only gave
them words and old destroyers for a
while but they were good words and
Roosevelt's heart was in the right place
I personally believe and again it's
subjective great
debate that if Roosevelt had moved
faster he probably would have lost the
1940 election and if you had a
Republican in the White House with their
Pacific bias in those days when Pearl
Harbor happened you might not have had
the European effort in the same way all
this is what if the reaching out to
Churchill was quite extraordinary is one
of the mysteries because he didn't like
him then he clearly remembered from from
1918 the Churchill hadn't liked him but
he needed anything he could do he didn't
trust Kennedy at that point he thought
Kennedy was a defeatist
he had very few contacts in England and
remember Franklin Roosevelt saw the
world as Hyde Park where he was the kind
of a country squire in charge of things
but everyone had their role in their
place the unites whole idea for the
United Nations was basically based on a
Hyde Park metaphor where there before
policemen and a village council he saw
the world as a global neighborhood side
it's a good metaphor actually it's as
we've learned it certainly is a
neighborhood so we better govern it like
one but that was that's basically the
view of Chamberlain and Chamberlain
course died fairly soon thereafter thank
you
could you please elaborate on the last
decade of Churchill's life and how well
he accepted his political demise
not well he was Winston Churchill was
first elected to Parliament in 1901
Queen Victoria was on the throne he was
coming back when she died his last
speech in the House of Commons in 1950s
last major speech in 1955 was about the
hydrogen bomb this is a man who galloped
in the last great cavalry charged in
British history a Tom Duran carrying a
Mauser pistol this is a man whose life
spanned the the whole of 20th century
and in the nineteenth he was a child of
the Victorian era as he called himself
but he was a man who always looked
forward one of the things I hope people
get out of this book is this idea that
Churchill was this hopeless backward
looking imperialist and Franklin
Roosevelt was this great futurist as aya
Berlin that was for his conceit and that
wonderful essay he wrote and with due
deference to the Blessed memory of Sir
Isaiah Winston Churchill never gave up
thinking about the future actually the
epigraph I used and in Franklin Winston
is the future is unknowable but the past
should give us hope which was one of the
last sentences of the history of the
english-speaking peoples which is one of
the books he finished in that last
decade he didn't accept it very well he
came back to power
poor Anthony Eden who always had a
brilliant future behind him was still
sort of riding along as the successor
and he was a I think it was a kind of
bittersweet retirement he loved the
arena he loved action
he loved movement one of the stories
that Charles II tells and and then in
the book is he was following shirts out
to a dinner one night and was stunned at
the speed with which the 65 year old
rather rotund not particularly
physically fit man could move and he
just moved moved moved and was vibrated
with energy he had to again de for the
productivity just remarkable one of the
sweeter stories
but it's in the very end of the book was
Jimmy Roosevelt went to see Churchill in
probably 62 or 63 Churchill died on the
24th of January 1965 the same date as
his father had died which he had
predicted the Jimmy went James Roosevelt
and Churchill shakes his hand and begins
talking about various letters and
various meetings and young Roosevelt
realizes that he thinks he's his father
and Churchill saw his mistake and as
Roosevelt put it just began to sag so at
least for a moment in an old man's mind
he'd been back at the pinnacle with
Franklin Roosevelt and the thought was
pleasing anything else I read recently
that there's some question about the
President Roosevelt's diagnosis and I
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit about that a few there is there's a
new article out just this this week last
week that it was a different kind of
syndrome I think the only historic I
don't know I haven't read the full
journal article I've ordered it but it
wasn't the daddy that was not polio I
think the only historical significance
has not the only but the main historical
significance has to be whether had that
diagnosis been made could something else
have been done that would have enabled
him to be more ambulatory and I don't
think that's the case that raises a very
good question about Roosevelt's physical
courage which is so remarkable and
Churchill saw it this was so interesting
in 1934 1934 Churchill at this point is
about as low in his political fortunes
as you could possibly be he as he put at
once he changed parties three times he
said anybody can rat that it takes
character to re rat
so he was just not doing very well and
was a chart woman was depressed and was
building walls and painting and writing
but he wrote a profile of Roosevelt for
Colliers magazine and it's remark a
remarkable document their dad recommends
for them to his profile of Hitler
Churchill's profile of Hitler and
Churchill's profile of Roosevelt served
quite prescient and quite interesting
and what he focused on was Roosevelt's
physical courage in rejoining political
life after his affliction now my friend
and great editor Charlie Peters of the
Washington Monthly is a very big
advocate at this point that yes we knew
he could not walk this idea that's come
up since the war that Roosevelt was this
is all secret that no one knew an
Englishman had never met him since his
affliction knew he couldn't walk
Churchill wrote very movingly not one
man in 10,000 would have rejoined life
not one man in ten millions could have
risen to the pinnacle and and fault the
good fights that he had fought so he
always admired that physical courage he
talks about his eulogy and I think one
of the more moving moments in the entire
relationship is the Sunday morning in
August of 1941 at the church parade on
the Prince of Wales a ship that was soon
to be sunk where they was very carefully
managed by Churchill he broke the
prayers he picked the hymns they sang Oh
God our help in ages past eternal father
strong to save and onward Christian
soldiers and Churchill said it was a
great hour to live every word seemed to
stir the heart and afterward Roosevelt
turned to his son Elliot and said we are
Christian soldiers and we will go on
with God's help
so Churchill had done well but Roosevelt
was intent upon not riding his chair
across the deck of the ship with these
British sailors who were fighting had
been in the war for at that point 20
almost 2 years and he as you all know he
lurched that's all he could do he had
steel braces and he had Elliot on one
side and a cane and literally just
forced himself forward across the deck
of the ship it was probably it may have
been the longest distance he'd walked
since he was afflicted but he was
determined to do it and one of the
British observers wrote that it was like
the face of a st. George slaying the
dragon
they were room that was they admired it
so much Jon Meacham is managing editor
of Newsweek his new book is Franklin and
Winston an intimate portrait of an epic
friendship it's published by Random
House online at Random House calm next
week on public lives David Herbert
Donald on the friendship